hey God what you've got a package hey
guys this Giga can welcome to my
unboxing video
hey guys Miki go with another unboxing
video now not everyone completely loves
unboxing video so this time I've got
[ __ ] [ __ ] two boxes [ __ ] more
boxes more boxes those are already open
but yeah let's unbox or some [ __ ] Lu
animate [ __ ] yeah now much you may be
watching this and wondering hey Giga
what does it take to become a skilled
unboxing like yourself and you're it's
it's pretty simple you know well all you
need to do is send your resume to [ __ ] I
really like opening boxes at gmail.com
this here is the this is the resume that
I sent you see so as we have two crates
of Sam I thought we can just do a double
unboxing just to save us some time I
didn't mention last time that each crate
is actually themed so you know that's
supposed to be jewel themed which has
stuff like jojo's you go and some other
[ __ ] and that's music theme which I'm
guessing has a lot of Miku [ __ ]
so loot crate let's see what you've
given me this time you can see here I
graduated from the box University with a
master's in an unboxing I achieved the
first degree actually I'm pretty proud
of that
and this is my cover letter that I sent
with the resume okay so apologies about
that like last month again it looks like
we got the crates mixed up with loot
crate sister company fruit crate it's a
lot like loot crate but just uh just
it's just the healthier option so let's
let's open some boxes
so the first thing I see is we got the
we've got a hypersonic t-shirt we go we
got an Ultraman t-shirt the first thing
I have to notice is that this is not a
low-cut top I mean how am I supposed to
make thousands of people uncomfortably
look at my chest hair without a low-cut
top come on Luke ray get it together
shut the [ __ ] up
we have a superfight anime deck I'm not
gonna pretend to know what this is so
I'm just gonna do a quick Google search
okay so apparently it's just death
battle the game where you have to argue
over which character will win I mean I
had a look at the demonstration oh wow
that's a nice thick she won't be able to
cast crap seems highly inaccurate
because nobody was shouting or swearing
or calling each other [ __ ] see yeah
the secret to becoming a great unboxers
that just cuz you're just gonna just
gonna be ready to open anything up for
people to see you see look so let's see
what we got here
oh you see here look see there is and
Maori cosplay we have some Phoenix
Wright ship and oh no no we got a
Phoenix Wright suitcase you know this is
pretty awesome I was always always
thinking about going to law school one
day and they like and I can definitely
use the suitcase for my homework and
stuff but I mean I don't know it seems
it seems a little small you know I don't
know how you're suppose for any
documents in this especially if you're a
law student I've heard you're supposed
to have a lot of homework so you know I
don't know it's loading practical but uh
you know you know whatever I didn't
really want to be a law student
oh man this is actually a lot of remote
cosplays we have the your line April
manga Wow now for those you haven't seen
the show yet avoid the manga is also
pretty good so know if you haven't read
the show you also pick up a lot
but you know that's why you should
definitely pick up your lie in April we
have some anime headphones to show
people with that I probably doesn't
listen to a lot of anime music I mean
these are great because you know when
someone asks me what music do I have on
my ipod I don't quite know how to say oh
well I mean I'm a huge fan of you know
the band Naruto opening seven or guilty
crown OST track nine oh hey it's my old
graphics card oh they gave me a leak and
this is this is this is pretty great you
know I could definitely do it with these
cuz you know I was actually planning to
cook some leek soup later so let me just
let me just put this away now it's
[ __ ] you yo socks
thanks Luke right I had no idea you had
the same taste in gifts as my grandma
but how the [ __ ] was I supposed to know
- oh really I am getting laid tonight
you want to leave you want to leak and
so we have a Miku lanyard and a Miku
travel blankets and can I just say how
[ __ ] high Miku looks on this [ __ ]
blanket so there's something I know a
bunch of you wanted me to address in a
last unboxing video there pani have made
a terrible mistake on ok you see this in
the last video this this right here is a
tangerine it's not an orange this is an
orange you see it's much larger and you
know it's also orange shaped so it's an
easy mistake but it's much larger and
it's not so easy to peel and this is an
apple and as usual we have little phone
chains and of course the posters wow I
did not know that so now had a
schoolgirl skin yet then finally wow we
have a jojo's cap you know what this is
pretty cool I think I actually know
someone who's gonna love this
so yeah those were the two queens if you
want any future installments of Luke
great then you can sign up at Luke
Raycom for next month with the details
that should be on the screen right now
makes my steam is apparently unity water
whatever that means now if you excuse me
I have an e Mario cosplay to finish use
coupon code Giga for 10% off